what your wrestling wrestling yeah my
wrestling you know you don't want Felix
no guanxi I know him I loved WOM WOM
yeah yeah I know Miss Guam yeah yeah to
be my roommate he lived in my closet
from really swarn Guam yeah and could
live in a like he's like a big guy now
but like ya keep posting a picture of
him like on Facebook like when he was
like a football stud in high school and
it's like a totally different look do
you hang out with Guam I used a lot he
used to my boy is he funny
I think he's very funny I haven't seen
him really yeah he's funny yeah I saw
him at a small urban all he is urban
yeah yeah yeah
were there guys in San Diego started
with that weren't funny well I mean
there's everywhere I think there aren't
funny
right but we are friends with them it's
hard to tell we especially when you're
starting yeah and there's guys around
you that just no they don't have it
you're so excited those people note they
don't have it like themselves they know
that don't know yeah right that's what
I'm saying they don't they don't know
they think they're doing well because
they see you and you're climbing in
there where's my turn there was a guy
I'm not gonna name his name but I lived
in Silver Lake and I've said this before
he used to come to my my apartment and
go check this out buddy I just killed at
whatever right and he play a tape I'm
not even kidding you you would hear it
complete just him talking what's I mean
it's so easy to know that if he killed
or not in comedy how do they not know
very very heavy clutter on the head
people don't know and you know what I
have the opposite effect I think that's
good what good comics have you have to
be a great judge yes no I'm almost like
people hate me because like Whitney
Cummings yells at me because she doesn't
think that like I'll have a good set and
go I just ate it oh one of those guys
yeah yeah and then she's like [ __ ] you
that type and I'm very annoying but do
you think other people ate it also when
they had a good set or is it just
yourself I think no I think everyone I
can't read because the laughs you get
from onstage is different from the
back of the room I see right I mean
you're you know a lot of times like
somebody will say I like I'll have an
opener that go that was hard
I don't know you're fine yeah I heard
you from the back of room and then I go
up on stairs I got oh my god the
acoustics is so weird you can't really
hear the laughs sure right so it depends
on what room you're playing but so I
can't tell unless I'm on stage but I'm
annoyingly yeah the other way over
critical when you were getting your
degree in economics were you already
going to open mics mmm
tourist lot when I turned 21 because
before that you have to wait outside
the clubs don't let you in so that was
probably my junior year or something
like that and that was when I started my
first open mic during the summer when I
was living my dad's here at the haha
comedy club oh you got to pay like five
bucks for like five minutes of stage
time
so I did that for like a couple months
did one bring her show and then that's
when I went back to San Diego and like
really pursued it cuz I just knew I
didn't know I could do stand-up yeah I
just know I really didn't want to do
economics so it oh so it wasn't even
something that you were absolutely dying
to get into no I I mean I I don't know
what your story is so many people like
my friends like oh man I used to watch
any Murphy's Nick in the backup theater
yeah brother when I was five years old
and I knew I want to be a stand-up and
now my brother died of lung cancer so
every time I go on stage it's for him I
hated economics and I did stand that I
was desperate you know that's it
oh no mine was like I my coffee shop
that I worked that closed I walked up to
it I just said clothes they didn't give
you a call because in the 90s they
didn't have we didn't have some all
right it's it closed forever when you
have a job and you you're that I was 23
I'll go next door cuz I to take them you
know we had large bills and I used to go
to the comments or to break them up at
nights so I knew the management
then they had a sign we needed a barback
so I knocked on the door I go hey can I
get a job because cuz they closed and
the fred burns less oh yeah you're the
kid from next door oh good yeah he goes
alright show up in two days you know at
not eight alright so I showed up and I
wash dishes
mmm you know and then I watched the open
mikes one night and I was I right you
know and I no offense but you know what
I started those guys like Chris clobber
in that whole regime they just didn't
like me because I think it was me I
think I was the bad guy I think I'm the
villain in this story because I'm very
opportunistic and I want to make it and
I I go oh [ __ ] I can hang out with
locals or I'll [ __ ] there's Carlos
Mencia right right I remember Carlos
sitting there with his he had a black
manager at the time named wordly
Patterson mm-hm
and I walked up to a Michael AJ I saw
your HBO special oh yeah cool bro
hey I just stand up to because let me
see you and I went up you let me go up
and worthy was their word he signed me
wow that's great
yeah but San Diego that's yeah I was
living in San Diego yeah and then Paulie
saw me open for me in Vegas right and
the locals were like look at this
[ __ ] guy right dude is a [ __ ]
cockroach yeah easily but they're in
their own way cuz they don't think I can
make it so they're not there but that's
that dude you just nailed it in the
[ __ ] head right now Jimmy Oh yang for
me okay you have to dream big absolutely
do did you dream big when you were like
working in madhouse and all those
[ __ ] places for sure like I I don't
know I've always had I'm
early business-minded so I knew I'm a
certain standard that I want to strive
towards where some people I guess don't
or they're in the own way yeah I feel
like like even like our friend Robert
who I think is very funny but it seems
like he's just stuck in San Diego like
he's in San Diego like so many feels
like oh man my set needs to get this
good to go up to LA my set nice to get
that goods like no man just [ __ ] come
up dude announcement right now I mean
I'm gonna make it I'm sorry for my
apartment I'm sorry baby I have to do
this I have an announcement you just we
just hit upon something okay all right
the announcement is this if you're scarm
ik and you live in a city right like
Austin it's great peoria wherever you
are right you gotta make the move you
gotta take but you gotta go to the big
[ __ ] pond yeah you got to be the
little fish for a while it feels good to
be in a small town and and run all these
rooms and everyone in locally knows who
you are but at the end of the day that's
dreaming small bro you got to dream big
man but I it's hard to say oh the only
thing is because like you don't want
every open mic did like two open mics to
come here you should get your craft
going maybe do a couple years and then
move up it but you you should make the
move no because I'll tell you why even
if they move up here la yeah they get
eaten up alive you know how hard it is
up here that scene yeah it's competitive
as [ __ ] bro yeah and let me tell you
something right now
I spent three years in San Diego and I
was like I think I can do it I'm gonna
conquer this [ __ ] town I walked up
here and I [ __ ] nearly I that's when
I developed boils on the face dress
boils yeah and that's where I really
found out what anger is what was the
plan when you came up to LA was it
become a regular at the store I was
already a recognized oh you were yeah
because I got lucky you know I got in
with Paulie early and then Mitzi saw me
when I opened for him in Vegas so I got
lucky in that way but that still wasn't
a leg up for me because when I moved up
here you just couldn't get spots even if
you were a regular at the store
already there's 10,000 regulars I mean
through the history of the Comedy Store
so many people got passed and they still
all of them want spots mm-hmm
so at that time you're like oh forgot
the wait in line so it was the worst
that what they did it was arm they do
these things called fall outs okay so
Mitzi would make a list of ten comics
twelve comics but there was another list
but you'd have to show up to sign up for
it it was called the fall out list and
so you'd have 20 guys show up or girls
and that were paid regulars and sign up
on the fall out list that's only if
somebody didn't show up but who would
not show so you're just sitting there
with 20 people going
I'm eighth on the follow-up is eight
people night but you would you would
stayed there till 2:00 in the morning
damn and every once awhile like there'll
be no crowd and you got like can I come
up just at the end right yeah it was
that brutal so how did you make it
what's big TV was your big break or is
it before that I'm sure maybe you talked
about no no no no I it's meeting leaving
worthy so I was with Carlos Mencia his
manager worthy Patterson great guy and
then I left him which broke his heart
for Midna for a B and what every Robin
no you don't know having but she's just
like this old Jewish lady now in that
lives in Venice but she was she at the
time had Laura chi-ling or Craig Anton a
lot of these guys Warren Hutchinson and
she had a stable of legitimate young
cool guys that were on TV so I was like
I signed with her and I think that was
my biggest and then I met Matt Blake my
agent now
[Music]